FISHER: Good morning.
I'm Peter Fisher.
I teach at the Tuck School of Business at
Dartmouth.
And when I was invited this morning to preside
over this panel, what came to mind was the
boyhood experience when my father was on sabbatical
in London, and my parents took my brother
and I to see the American comedian Danny Kaye
conduct the London Philharmonic Orchestra.
(Laughter.)
It was a one-gag evening, which is, the London
Philharmonic is so good, it doesn't need a
conductor.
(Laughter.)
Now, given who I have up with me on the stage,
I feel like Danny Kaye.
(Laughter.)
But I hope I'll be as good as he was at getting
out of the way.
So, without further ado, you have everyone's
biographies in your book.
But, briefly put, we have here Rana Foroohar,
the assistant managing editor of Time Magazine
and the author of the new book, "Maker and
Takers: The Rise of the Finance and the Fall
of American Business"; John Lipsky, former
first deputy managing director of the-something
called the International Monetary Fund-(laughter)-and
a senior fellow at the John(s) Hopkins School
of Advanced International Studies; and we
have Joseph Stiglitz, a university professor
at Columbia Business School.
And we're here to discuss "Is U.S. Finance
Hurting Growth?"
And I'm going to pose the same question to
each of you in sequence-I think Rana, Joe,
John.
Do we have too much or too little finance?
Is it hurting us or helping us?
And over what horizon are you thinking about?
Rana?
FOROOHAR: OK, I'll kick it off.
Well, first of all, let me say thank you for
having me here.
I'm incredibly honored to be on a stage with
all of you.
I am a humble journalist and not a trained
economist.
But I've been a business and economic journalist
for 23 years, and so my perspective in my
book is really built off of that observation
and talking to very smart people like the
ones on stage about what's going on in the
global economy.
So I began working on my book about three
years ago in the wake of the financial crisis
because I was trying to understand why there
was still such an incredible divide between
Wall Street and Main Street, and in particular
where the markets were, and where the real
economy was, and what was that divide about.
I was going and, you know, talking to companies
and seeing individuals in various parts of
the country, and they just simply were not
feeling the recovery in the same way that
the markets were perceiving them.
So I began digging into it-the research, essentially,
on finance and growth.
And what I came to find was that I think the
nature of the financial system in the U.S.
has changed profoundly over the last 40 years.
I actually do in my book a kind of a hundred-year
overview, because I wanted to compare the
run-up to the Great Depression with the period
in the run-up to the subprime crisis.
But I would say that the period of what I
call "financialization," the modern period,
started about 40 years ago.
And during that time, the size of the financial
sector as a percentage of the economy has
almost quadrupled.
So it's gone from 2 1/2 (percent), 3 percent,
to close to 8 percent.
But during that time, trend growth, of course,
has not grown.
And there have been a number of metrics about
number of startups falling, entrepreneurial
zeal going down by a variety of measures,
R&D spending going down relative to, say,
share buybacks in companies, that show that
business has actually suffered as finance
has gotten bigger.
And there's a lot of studies-it's all cited
in the books, so-and there's smart people
who've done some of these studies on the-on
the stage here, so I won't go into them.
But basically, by a lot of metrics, the size
of finance in the U.S. has started to slow
growth.
And, in fact, there's some studies, BIS studies
and others, that show that that happens actually
when finance is just half the size that it
is in the U.S. right now.
But then the other thing that I would mention-and
I was very interested as I began to speak
to different academics about this-is the nature
of change in what the financial sector does.
So, if you go back to kind of, you know, the
original nature of what the capital markets
were supposed to do to business, they're supposed
to take everybody's savings, you put it in
financial institutions, the financial institutions
lend that money out to business, business
grows and creates jobs.
Actually, there are some deep academic studies
that show about only 15 percent of all the
financial flows in the U.S. financial institutions
right now are going to business lending.
The rest of it is basically trading against
existing assets-stocks, bonds, houses, the
real estate market being a large part of that,
of course.
And then so I try and get into the ramifications
of this for business in a variety of chapters
in my book.
And I'll just leave one last stat before I
pass the baton here.
One of the fascinating things that I found-and
I explored this through stories of a number
of companies-is that business itself has come
to emulate finance.
So, if you look at the amount of revenue that
businesses across all industries are getting
now from financial services, from financial
tactics like tax optimization, that's increased
fivefold since the 1980s.
So it's almost as though we've all become
bankers.
And finance has become, in my view, the tail
that wags the dog for industry, rather than
the other way around.
So I'll stop there.
FISHER: Thank you.
Joe, too much, too little, or the wrong mix?
STIGLITZ: Well, first let me say Rana's book
is fantastic, so I'd encourage all of you-she
can't say that, but I can say that.
(Laughter.)
So it is really interesting.
The basic perspective that Rana put, that
there's been this enormous increase in the
relative size of the financial sector to GDP
without any evidence that this has led to
any benefit to economic growth, there are
actually two other aspects of this that I'd
just mention briefly.
Looking across countries, one is that-a study
that I did with Bill Easterly when I was chief
economist of the World Bank, which showed
that, if you look at instability, as you increase,
there's a-there's a U-shaped curve.
Some degree of finance is very important-diversifies
risk, so it's an important function.
But if you look across countries, when it
gets too big, there's more instability.
And, of course, instability is bad not only
for growth, but for a whole other set of effects.
The second thing that-Jamie Galbraith has
a nice book that describes, is there's a systematic
relationship between the degree of financialization
and inequality.
And for a whole variety of reasons, not a
surprise.
The real question, though, is, when you start
looking at the micro-not the macro, but look
underneath-and you ask the question, what
is the financial sector doing and, like Rana
said, where are they making money?
It turns out a very large fraction of their-of
their revenues come not from the core activities
that we model the financial sector-you know,
that lending activity, that risk mitigation,
those kinds of things that are core-but from
all kinds of, you might say, antisocial activities-(laughter)-like
LIBOR manipulation, forex manipulation.
I don't want-you know, hard to quantify.
Some of, though, you-has been quantified.
You ask questions like using market power
over the medium of exchange, the rents they
extract in interchange fees are very significant.
And that's where the big-you know, there's
been a lot-an attempt to curb it a little
bit in Dodd-Frank, but the Fed really missed
it.
And the Dodd-Frank only focuses on debit cards,
not-didn't do anything about credit cards.
Schiller and Akerlof had this very nice book
called "Phishing for Phools," where they use
the word-"ph," picking up on the internet-that
a very large part of the revenue comes from
trying to find people that they can take advantage
of.
And there are a lot of fools out there.
And you might say, globalization opened up
a global market for fools, and they were very
good at finding them.
You know, a little village in Norway or, you
know.
So that contrast with another study that's
cited in Rana's book, which is that the efficiency
of the sector in providing the services that
it does, you would have thought the cost would
have gone down because it's basically a tech
sector, you know?
It's processing data.
And our technology has been-you know, Moore's
Law has brought down that cost-doesn't show
up in the cost that they charge for those
kinds of services.
So that comes to the question that you posed,
Peter, which is, the question isn't just the
size of the financial sector, that it's doing
too much of what it shouldn't and not enough
of what it should do.
And then this comes to the core regulatory
issues that we've been debating since the
financial crisis.
Most of what the debate has been focused on
is stopping the financial sector from imposing
harms on the rest of the society.
Very little of it has been addressed to the
question, how do we actually make the financial
sector do what we hope it's supposed to do?
And which is very important.
So, you know, I'm very much in favor of the
financial sector.
I think the financial sector is really important.
The real problem is it hasn't been doing as
much-you know, it's been diverted from performing
those core functions.
And just one closing remark is, you know,
there's a-you might-you may say almost a personal
aspect of this, of how it adversely affects
our growth.
A disproportionately large fraction of our
best students, you know, and my best students,
wind up in finance, for good reason; it's
where the money is, and they're reasonably
rational.
But one would have hoped that there would
have been more diversification, more of them
would have gone into other areas of inquiry-you
know, public service, research, you know.
So I think one of the reasons why it has not
had the positive effect that you would have
hoped, I mean, is that it has distorted the
structure of our economies.
And not only is the financial sector distorted,
there's a distortion in the whole structure
of our-of our economy.
FISHER: Thank you, Joe.
John, too much, too little, what horizon?
LIPSKY: (Laughs.)
Well, I've chosen to interpret this question
a little more narrowly, but before that just
say Joe is an old friend and absolutely brilliant,
but he obviously doesn't work in a financial
institution.
(Laughter.)
So he hasn't had to watch his margins shrink,
he hasn't had to watch the onslaught of new
regulation, he hasn't had to deal with the
historically unprecedented monetary policy
that has produced a very adverse environment
for profitability, and he hasn't had to worry
about all the hotshot young grads heading
off to Silicon Valley to join fintech firms
that are-certain are going to cannibalizing
the evil banks.
And it seems to me, when you're thinking about
this, the-two aspects of this conversation
that need to be kept in mind.
The last 40 years, or 60 years, since World
War II, has seen a dramatic transformation
of the global economy that has produced fantastic
and unprecedented challenges.
And this is an-I tend to, when I hear about
this in the financial sector, I don't think
the most powerful forces have been created
by the financial sector; I would say have
been reflected in the financial sector.
Of course, there's a-this is simultaneous,
there's feedback.
But I don't think that the most powerful forces
have come from the financial sector; quite
the-quite the other way around.
And in that context, the notion that let's
think about national markets has becoming
progressively less relevant.
And yet, so much of the discussion has been
around national markets, and so much of the
response to the crisis has been by national
regulators and authorities to try to ring
fence their market, such that international
markets have become less efficient and less
effective over time.
So I've interpreted the question, the topic
today, to ask, have we-post-crisis, we clearly
faced a challenge on, one, restoring global
growth; number two, improving financial-sector
stability so we never saw another global financial
crisis like we just had.
It's quite remarkable, seven or eight years
on from the onset of the crisis, depending
on how you want to time it, this regulatory
reform is still a work in progress.
And some of the most powerful measures have
yet to-yet to be enacted.
Quite remarkable.
Even Dodd-Frank, which has produced about
22,000 pages of legislation and regulation,
is still incomplete.
And the changes in regulation have forced
very costly action on financial institutions
that-and I would say, if there's a criticism,
not that there wasn't-that change wasn't necessary,
but I would say that the-there has been insufficient
attention given to the overall impact to a
whole series of regulatory and legal measures
that were taken in a little bit of a-and I
don't want to sound condescending, but a little
bit of a whac-a-mole kind of a manner.
Here was a problem, whack.
Here's another problem, whack.
Is anybody standing back and saying, what
are we doing to the system?
I don't think so.
Here are two little examples.
Anti-money laundering, financing of terrorism:
we've decided that bankers and financial institutions
need to also be policemen.
Now that's all well and good-that's all well
and good, but a collateral damage has been
of the effort in anti-money laundering to
collapse correspondent banking relationships
worldwide, and deprived some of the most-some
of the poorest nations from access to modern
banking.
Did the folks designing this think about that?
I don't think so.
Second, when we talk about the wonderful profitability
of the banking system, most of the large banks
in the U.S. and in Europe trade today below
book value.
That's hardly a recipe for producing-for supporting
growth, and supporting growth over time.
So I would say, have the-if the question is,
have the reforms so far hindered growth, which
have-has the U.S. financial system hindered
growth, I would say, yes, this is true.
At the same-relative to what it might have
been.
Have it-has these changes, at the same time,
enhanced stability?
I would say, yes, they have.
But do we have the tradeoff right?
I'm not at all convinced.
I'll stop there.
FISHER: Let me pick on an early point John
made, and press Rana and Joe.
Let's put aside front-running customers and
abusing.
Yes, that happens.
But is it causation, or is it correlation,
or is it a secondary effect?
We have 40 years of falling interest rates.
We squeeze-and the central banks of the world
squeezed inflation out of the system from
1982 to 2002.
We're surprised that the value of holding
financial assets, it's a lucrative thing to
be in the business of holding these things,
asset-based finance.
And so we watched the financial sector grow
in size while you bring down the discount
rate on all those future cash flows.
Does that mean it caused the decline in growth?
Robert Gordon is pretty gloomy, but I don't
recall-and I read every page of his book-him
putting a lot of weight on the financial sector
as dragging down productivity.
He's got plenty of other causes he's pointing
to.
So I see correlation, and I may see secondary
effect, but to say the financial sector got
up in the morning and did it, putting aside
abusive client, is a little harder for me,
even though I sort of see what you're driving
at.
Let me press you both on that.
FOROOHAR: Well, so, it's a really good point.
And I would just say, and I mentioned this
in my book, that financialization, globalization,
and technological job destruction are definitely
moving in tandem, and in some ways create
snowball cycles with each other.
I mean, you know, one of the things I explore
is how in corporations, the CFO's office-I
look at this topic culturally as well, just
to preface-the CFO's office, and the sort
of way in which corporate management has become
very balance-sheet oriented, leads to certain
decisions around outsourcing, for example,
that a lot of companies are starting to reconsider
now.
You know, there is-there is a tremendous movement
to reshore and rethink the typical Finance
101 teaching of, you know, marshal your capital,
you know, cut costs, worry about talent, worry
about everything else later.
I think that there's a big shift.
And actually I think that that's for the reason
that you're talking about.
The traditional business school teaching for
executives, which is very financially oriented,
is actually very out of date for the challenges
of the day, in part because we are awash in
a world of capital.
There's plenty of money sloshing around.
And so making decisions based on that, which
is a very financialized way to make corporate
decisions, actually doesn't work as well.
And I have some great anecdotes from different
corporate leaders in my book about that.
So I think causality is difficult to prove.
I'm also struck, though, and I'm remembering
Rajan's comment in his book.
The central banker of India used to teach
at University of Chicago that "let them eat
credit" could be sort of the mantra for the
last 40 years.
And this goes along with exactly what you're
saying.
Low interest rates, in some ways, policies
taken across different administrations, both
Republican and Democratic, that mask underlying
growth problems with easy money and easy credit,
and I see this as part of the process of financialization.
STIGLITZ: So, you know, obviously it's always
difficult to separate causation correlation,
particularly there are many factors.
So no one will say it is the factor that has
caused the slowdown in economic growth; it
is one of the factors.
But as one thinks about it, there are several
channels by which it has, both by what it's
done and what it's not done, so let me talk
about it.
One of them is I think it's unambiguous that
it has contributed, not only in the United
States, but in other countries, to more instability.
That most people would say that it did play
a role in the buildup in the bubble that led
to the crisis.
Now, you could say it was low interest rates.
But the financial sector was supposed to manage
risk, you know, it was not supposed to be
engaged in massive fraud.
It was supposed to-you know, securitization
was about risk diversification well-managed,
OK?
It didn't happen.
And so if you read, like, the report of the
Financial Inquiry Commission, very clear that
it was some of the things that the financial
sector did and didn't do that played a very
big role in the crisis of 2008.
And there's no doubt that crises are bad for
economic growth.
They have long-term effects.
We still are not really recovered from the
effects of the crisis.
So that's one example.
A second one is a broader-let me say really
the same thing that Rana did, in a slightly
different language.
What do CEOs focus on?
What do corporations focus on?
Making a better product or manipulating taxes
and deciding where to locate based on tax
advantages?
You know, that kind of financial management
versus innovation, real sector management.
And there's a, you know, a well-developed
theory about managerial attention being limited,
and when you focus on one thing you're not
focusing on another.
So the financialization of the economy more
broadly I think has diverted the attention
of corporate America away from some of the
real things that would have increased productivity.
And finally, it goes back, you know, again,
to pick up the word that Rana said.
If you look at what we model the financial
sector as doing, which is taking money from
savers, intermediating, and providing it to
firms that are going to lead to more economic
growth, that's not what's been going on in
the country.
In fact, there are these studies that show
that, on average, money is flowing out of
the corporate sector.
So its traditional role that we describe in
the textbook of intermediating between savers
and investors isn't there.
One strong way of looking at this from a global
point of view-you know, we're at the Council
on Foreign Relations, so think about it from
a global point of view-is Ben Bernanke remember
said that we had a savings glut.
And when he said it, you know, from a perch
of somebody who does a lot of work in development
and a lot of concern about climate change,
my reaction was he was living on a different
planet than I was, that I looked around the
world and I said we need so much money for
retrofitting the global economy, for climate
change, so much money for infrastructure.
Even New York City we know has some problems.
And so you look, say, look, we have a shortage
of finance.
So you ask the question, how do you reconcile
his view with the view, you know, you open
your eyes, you say we aren't financing the
investment we need.
And the answer is, between those two is supposed
to be a financial sector, and particularly
a lot of the savings is long term, pension
funds, sovereign wealth funds who are long-term
horizon.
The investment needs are long-term needs,
long-term infrastructure.
But sitting between the two is a financial
sector, that is often looking at quarterly,
daily, nanosecond, can't serve that need of
intermediating between long-term savers and
long-term investors.
So my view has been, you know, that there's
a real dysfunction here in its ability to
do what it's supposed to do from a global
perspective.
FISHER: Well, let me push back and then see
if John wants to pick up the mantle just for
the fun of it.
(Laughter.)
Ben Bernanke's savings glut struck me as the
wrong side of the coin.
STIGLITZ: Yeah.
FISHER: We had a glut of consumption and excessive
income here, which is how China ended up with
a savings glut, and they financed our glut
of consumption and excessive income.
It started here.
And that was from the accommodative monetary
policy, stimulating the interest rate-sensitive
sectors of the economy, housing and autos.
And when housing and autos collapsed, oh,
dear, it wasn't the fault of monetary policy,
it was the fault of something called financial
stability in the financial sector and washing
its hands of it and saying, what, me, worry,
I didn't do that when, of course, accommodative
policy in 2003, '(0)4 and '(0)5 did that.
But I want, John-you can jump in after John
and then we'll open it up.
LIPSKY: OK, OK.
Look, let's look at this in a number of ways.
If we're talking post crisis, post crisis
there has been a dramatic decline in leverage
in the financial sector.
Right?
In fact, in the U.S. it's about by half and
in Europe nearly by half.
So again, if we come back, have the changes,
the latest changes in the economic sector,
the financial sector tended to retard credit
availability and growth?
I would say yes, yeah.
It seems pretty clear.
And again, I come back to saying that doesn't
necessarily mean it's bad, but there certainly
has been a tradeoff between stability, enhancing
stability, and growth.
The idea about that there hasn't been-that
everybody's been busy trading and no one's
been paying any attention to the real economy,
geez, Joe, you used to be at Stanford.
You probably haven't been out there recently.
STIGLITZ: No, I have.
(Laughs.)
LIPSKY: Oh, OK.
Well, you go up on Sand Hill Road and you'll
see it's crawling-
STIGLITZ: Small percentage.
FOROOHAR: Tiny.
STIGLITZ: Small percentage of the financial
sector.
LIPSKY: There we go.
But it's-yeah.
STIGLITZ: It's important.
LIPSKY: Thank you.
Thank you.
STIGLITZ: Exactly.
But I would like to see a lot more Sand Hills.
LIPSKY: Very good, very good.
(Laughter.)
And let's think about, what does the sector
really look like, the financial sector in
the U.S.?
The U.S. bond market is about $40 trillion
outstanding.
Equity market's about 25 trillion (dollars)
The U.S. investment managers of that control
about 45 trillion (dollars), and the banking
sector about 18 trillion (dollars).
So it's actually relatively small.
So when we think about what are we talking
about in terms of who's doing what, it seems
to me a lot of the discussion focuses on aspects
or should say global hedge funds.
Globally hedge funds control about 2 1/2 trillion
(dollars), relatively small, small amount.
So it seems to me a lot of the attention gets
focused not on the bread-and-butter and meat-and-potatoes.
So what we've been lacking in this economy
has been not consumption demand, but investment,
right?
And right now, the market, not only does the
market send a signal to banks to say you are
not currently investable, your price-to-book
is below 1, so why would I give my money to
a bank so they can reduce value-added?
And at the same time, it strikes me when you
look at the equity market more broadly, which
has nothing to do with the banking system
directly, you can see that corporate management
is being incentivized to conduct share buybacks
because that's what seems to get valued in
the market.
So it seems to me to say so this is a problem
that is caused by the financial sector.
I'm certainly not trying to say there is no
problem that the sector can't be improved,
but I doubt if that is the primary locus of
the problems of this economy.
FOROOHAR: Can I just follow up on a couple
of point?
FISHER: Yes.
FOROOHAR: I've also been really interested
in this idea that the largest banks are trading
at relatively low valuations.
You know, to me, in some ways, the markets
are actually giving a signal about the structure
of banking, because if you look at what banking
analyst reports say, they would work better
and be, you know, more highly valued if they
were broken up.
Now, this is not a Bernie Sanders, you know,
break up the big banks, it's a silver bullet
for getting rid of risk.
We all know that that's not a silver bullet.
And in fact, Joe did an amazing report for
the Roosevelt Institute on how there is no
silver bullet because this is a 40-year process
that's been tiny, little, incremental changes,
each of which require looking at.
But I would also say that in my book and as
I think of finance, I'm looking not just at
the formal banking sector, but at shadow banking,
at all the ways in which risk is moving into
places that are even more opaque.
I mean, I totally agree with you.
Definitely Dodd-Frank has reduced risk and
leverage ratios in the formal banking sector,
but risk has gone to many other places.
And what's really interesting to me is that
the corporate sector, I mean, the corporate
bond market, the corporate junk bond market
has become a place where risk now lies.
And big tech companies are underwriting corporate
bond offerings the way Goldman Sachs, you
know, would, but they're not regulated in
the same way.
So the entire-it is a larger ecosystem.
And I do agree with you on the thing that
we spend way too much time, I think, in a
really siloed conversation about, you know,
how much tier-one capital JPMorgan should
be holding.
We should be looking at a much bigger ecosystem
of finance and let's study where is the risk
and what should the system be doing, per Joe's
point.
LIPSKY: Sure.
FISHER: Joe gets the last word before I open
it up to questions.
LIPSKY: OK.
(Laughs.)
FISHER: I want to get one little bit.
I know, you'll get quite a few.
(Laughs.)
STIGLITZ: So one way of thinking about it,
you know, go back sort of to textbooks economics.
If you lower the cost of capital, you know,
monetary policy, the standard economics would
be that lower cost of capital, that money
goes into more investment that stimulates
economic growth.
But between what the Fed does and Main Street
is the financial sector.
And I'll use the financial sector in a very
broad term, like Rana, not just the banks,
but a whole industry, OK, out there and some
of it even in the corporate sector when they
engage.
GE Capital was as much part of the financial
sector as any other.
So I don't want to-it needs to be interpreted
in a very broad way.
So you would have thought if we had a well-functioning
economy and a well-functioning financial sector,
the low cost of capital would have stimulated
a lot of investment and that would be a period
of high economic growth.
There was nothing that said that that low
cost of capital would be translated into lots
of consumption, you know, a housing bubble.
But that's really where the debate, in some
sense, is.
The central role of the financial sector is-two
of the central functions are allocating capital
to create a productive economy, and managing
risk.
And I'd say it failed on both.
It allocated capital not to this productive
use that is part of the textbook, you go down
to your investment banker and you have a lot
of investment, but to consumption and to existing
assets creating asset bubbles.
And that was not the attention in the Fed.
I don't think-you know, I agree with you,
very critical of the Fed of its understanding
that the translation of credit into productive
activities, that chain is a very weak chain
and it could actually go the other way.
And I think they still haven't fully appreciated
that.
A second aspect of this that you often see,
you know, low interest rates, people say that
causes more volatility because there's this
reach for yield and people put their money
into more risky assets.
In a standard, rational model that underlies
most of macroeconomics, that doesn't happen.
You know, just because the interest rate is
lowered doesn't mean you act in a more reckless
way.
In fact, it should go the other way.
So the bottom line is that our models of behavior
are wrong.
I agree with you, macroeconomic policy is
wrong.
But the financial sector has not guided either
the allocation of capital or the management
of risk in ways that you would have hoped
it would have done to promote economic growth.
So that period of low interest rates should
have been a period of enormous economic growth
and stability, but it wasn't.
FISHER: All right.
I'm going to let the audience get in on the
action now, our members.
I was remiss in not saying this is an on-the-record
session, but our guests all knew that in advance.
FOROOHAR: Everything is on the record.
FISHER: So now you know this was an on-the-record
session.
And let me ask you to identify yourself.
We have microphones roaming around.
Identify yourself, pose your question quickly,
and then we'll try to have a dialogue.
So here, right there, sir.
Q: Thank you very much.
Mahesh Kotecha.
My question is regarding, you know, the problem
that John raised, which is, are we looking
at the bread-and-butter as it were, the shadow
banking system versus the real banking system?
The banking system relative to the shadow
banking system is actually not what it used
to be.
It is, as you pointed out, it's smaller.
So the regulation typically goes to the regulated
side, missing the boat.
What do you do about that?
And are we successful in getting to the unregulated
sector which seems to be the tail that wags
the dog?
LIPSKY: That was just the point I was going
to make.
(Laughter.)
So you were-
FISHER: I was right.
LIPSKY: You predicted accurately.
Absolutely, the source of the problem, which
also reflected incentives, including government
incentives, including a housing sector that
is probably the most distorted of any large
economy in the world, and the response to
the crisis has been to pile more incentive
into the housing sector, that the source was
not the regulated banking system, but the,
let's call it, shadow banking and nonregulated
or more lightly regulated sector.
Back at the IMF, we had five conclusions of
what needed to be done with regard to fixing
the system.
One was more capital, but two was to improve
regulations.
And the primary problem that we saw with the
regulatory environment was a misdrawing of
the perimeter of regulation that left systemically
important institutions outside the perimeter
of regulation.
And that has not been largely changed in that
almost all the regulation has focused so far
on the banking system.
And, Rana, one of the reasons why large banks
are poorly valued in the market is because
they're in the process of attracting fantastic
capital charges that call into question their
viability.
It has nothing to do with the underlying business,
but has to do with regulatory decisions in
which, for example, with TLAC coming up, total
loss-absorbing capital charges, the two banks
in the world that sailed through the crisis
without batting an eye, never worrying for
a minute that they were under threat, are
going to attract by far the highest charges.
STIGLITZ: Can I say, this is an avenue where
John and I agree, it sounds like.
(Laughter.)
LIPSKY: I hope we agree on a lot, Joe.
STIGLITZ: We agree.
We do agree on a lot.
And I just would raise two or three more points.
One of them is, one has to ask the question,
why do we have a shadow banking system?
And part of it is actually to circumvent the
regulations.
And to the extent that that is true, we really
ought to be asking, you know, is the issue
should we-we really ought to bring it all
in in some ways.
It's a little bit like the question, you know,
an easier question is, why do we have offshore
banking?
You know, is it that finance really does better
in the Cayman Islands because of the sunshine?
(Laughter.)
You know, that makes money grow faster.
Or is there something else going on?
And we all know the answer to that.
It's not like, you know, the expertise in
New York and in London isn't up to the expertise
that they have in British Virgin Islands.
So we know the answer.
So the question is, why don't we just shut
it down?
FISHER: We have a global collective action
problem is the answer.
(Laughter.)
Another question from the audience, who would
like to jump in?
Yes, sir.
Wait for the mic and identify yourself and
your affiliation.
Q: Sorry.
Jim Shapiro from the Tata Group.
I just wonder if any of you would like to
comment on the failure of fiscal policy relative
to all this.
I mean, you mentioned the obvious role of
monetary policy, but one of the real failures,
it seems to me, in terms of driving the investment,
much of which needed to be public investment
or at least publicly led investment, is really
just a governmental failure in the U.S. and
in other countries.
And what part-how much does that sort of explain
some of what-
FISHER: I'm going to intervene and translate
just because I want to see how Lipsky-(laughter)-will
respond.
FISHER: I have a shortcut to that.
I've tried to teach my students at Dartmouth
without making them read the entire general
theory.
Why did Keynes become a Keynesian?
Because he gave up on monetary policy.
He didn't just from a vacuum decide the state
should do it, you know, because gee I can't
think of anything else.
He sat there in 1935 and '36 and said: Fiddling
with the rate of interest in order to simulate
private credit to get investment going just
isn't going to do it.
So let me see how they respond to that.
STIGLITZ: Oh, I totally agree with that perspective.
And the view-so the question, in a way, is
it is a failure of fiscal policy.
They should have used even louder-they did
say this-that they should have used even louder
the bully pulpit and said: We can't do it.
It's really your responsibility.
And that was a failure, not-there was a little
bit of, I think, a failure to do more about
increasing the credit channel.
The credit channel was broken and there was
more that they could have done to think about
why it was broken and what could be done about
making it better.
But the next question is, given that the fiscal
policy wasn't working, what should monetary
policy have done?
The first is making the credit channel work
better, but then the question is, say they
can't do that.
Should they have lowered the interest rates
to the level-are they having a productive
or a counterproductive effect?
And I think that's-you know, I think that's
open to debate.
FISHER: Yes, ma'am.
Microphone here, please.
Q: I'm Lucy Komisar.
I'm Lucy Komisar.
I'm a journalist.
And I've written for many years about the
offshore banking corporate secrecy system.
So I'd like to ask Joe, how would you shut
it down?
STIGLITZ: Well, in a way I'm-this picks up
a little bit on what John said and what we
did in the Anti-Terror Act, you know.
We did really-we cut off correspondence relationships.
It had some adverse effects on some countries,
but it had-it worked.
The system of financing for terrorism really-I
think it was an effective system.
So if we had a resolve to do it, and there
would be a debate about the collateral damage
and John would-(laughter)-I think it would
probably-it would be worth doing is precisely
things like the correspondence banking.
You say, lookit, if you're not willing to
sign up to these standards, you can't have
correspondent relationships.
FISHER: John?
LIPSKY: Look, that's not really the problem,
Joe.
The problem is you're responsible for your
correspondents living up to the standards
the correspondent said.
And you get this tremendous imbalance of risk
and reward, namely if your correspondent bank-the
guy you've trusted actually fail, you're going
to get-you're going to get a huge-
STIGLITZ: Yeah, but I'm answer his question
on how you do it.
LIPSKY: Yeah, yeah, but there's another aspect
that's actually even more important.
And that's what now goes under the BEPS, base
erosion profit shifting, that there is-the
big money for tax authorities in governments
is not in stopping money laundering or financing
of terrorism.
It's really to make sure that you end up with
collecting the taxes that you think are due.
And that-there's a big effort-you know this-there's
a big effort on that score.
STIGLITZ: But that has not gone anywhere far
enough.
I mean-
LIPSKY: But I think the idea of tax havens
are disappearing.
The notion, for instance, of Swiss bank secrecy
is long gone, et cetera, et cetera.
So I think that's changed.
Can I come for just a second to the question
on fiscal policy?
Two things.
I think in the immediate response to the crisis
the U.S. did a couple good things in terms
of credit.
TARP, which started out on a silly idea, the
troubled asset, right?
They were going to buy back bad assets.
In the end, they just said we're going to
recapitalize them.
We're going to guarantee the recapitalization
of the banks.
And then couple that with stress testing.
That did a lot.
What's missing?
The common-the conventional wisdom is infrastructure.
OK, yes, but my experience in my career is
to watch it.
Just because somebody calls something an investment
doesn't mean it's really a good investment.
And you can waste money on bad investments
big time-
STIGLITZ: Like housing in Nevada in the desert,
like the private financial sector did?
LIPSKY: Yeah.
Well, you mean there was no public incentive
to-you know, in the housing sector?
STIGLITZ: Nobody told them to invest in the
desert.
LIPSKY: No, I'm not trying to say that nobody
made any mistakes, I'm just saying that let's
not say just because something's infrastructure
that we should spend whatever.
And then finally interest-I learned in public
finance 101, just today's interest rate is
low doesn't mean you should engage in a 50-year
live asset based on today's rate, because
you may actually-if this is distorted by public
policy-you may be effectively ripping off
savers in the long run, which you may not
want to do.
FOROOHAR: Can I-
FISHER: Rana wants to jump in.
LIPSKY: That's not to say that more couldn't
have been done.
And then finally tax reform is long overdue.
FOROOHAR: Oh, yeah.
Well, I was going to jump in on that too.
I just want to say one thing on fiscal policy.
I think it's worth pointing out that this
is a long-standing problem.
This isn't even just a post-2008 problem.
I actually looked in the first chapter in
my book at the ways in which at many points
when there was political contentiousness and
disagreement about how to deal with an underlying
growth problem-you know, from the 1970s onward,
really-that easy money, you know, pushing
the ball to the market, saying let the markets
figure it out is a way that politicians have
always managed these more difficult problems.
So I think that's one important thing.
The other thing-I just wanted to say, just
one kind of colorful story that I think speaks
to the tax issues-the offshore tax issue,
and the tension points between finance and
business, and really I think the Kafkaesque
way in which the markets have developed.
If you just look at Apple, for example.
Apple has about $2 billion sitting in bank
accounts, many of them offshore.
It has made promises and issued I'm not sure
how many tens of billions of dollars of debt
in the last three years-but it has made promises
to issue almost that amount of debt here at
home in the bond markets, because it's cheaper,
obviously.
And they don't want to pay the higher corporate
tax rate.
That money is being paid out to, you know,
people-until recently, people like Carl Icahn,
activist investors, the top ten percent of
the population that owns 80 percent of the
stock.
Which does to Joe's point about how financialization
increase inequality.
And it's also just bizarre, because it makes
you wonder what are the capital markets for?
I mean, corporations are involved in the capital
markets more than ever before, at a time when
they don't actually need any capital, you
know?
(Laughs.)
Which is sort of a very question that I think
is important to keep in mind here.
FISHER: Yes, Mr. Tempelsman.
Here comes a microphone.
Q: Maurice Tempelsman.
Thank you very much for a good debate.
One participant absent on this stage, if one
looks back at, say, the last 100 to 150 years,
in this search for growth-motivation for growth
and stability, ranging all the way from state
ownership to total laissez-faire, or triumphalism
of laissez-faire, the political factor has
been totally omitted.
And I think the interaction between the political-what
if feasible, what is doable-versus what is
possibly desirable in an imperfect world is
something which is a very important-as we
see it in our present political-(inaudible)-with
both the left and the right, with different
methodology, different-really mining the same
political load.
Can you comment on that?
FISHER: Yeah.
Can you say a word about that?
LIPSKY: Yes.
Real briefly.
You've touched on something I feel very deeply
about.
It seems to me that when the crisis hit in
2007, 2008, it produced collective action
on a scale we've never seen before.
The principal institutional response to the
crisis was the formation of the G-20 at the
leaders' level.
And the cooperation shown, for example, between
November 2008 and April 2009, the London summit,
I think everybody agrees had a tremendously
positive effect on ameliorating the downturn
and setting the stage for an upturn.
I, for one, hope that that would be a lesson
learned that would produce a much more cooperative
and collaborative approach to macroeconomic
policy setting that was originally established
in Pittsburgh in September of 2009 in the
formation of what we called the framework
for strong, sustainable, and balanced growth-an
initiative that I thought showed tremendous
progress in the idea of collaboration, not
I'll sacrifice for the greater good, but that
if we all work together we can produce, create
a superior result that leaves everybody better-at
least as well off or better off than before.
And how much have you heard about this effort
from the political leaders?
It's still going on at a technical level,
but there's just been no political follow
through.
And I've been bitterly disappointed with that.
STIGLITZ: Yeah, and can I just say one word
about that?
And that goes back to the macro or the fiscal.
The view, particularly of Germany, that austerity
is the solution has really led to-I think
played an important role in undermining the
ability to reach a coordinated solution, because
there are just very deep political divide-philosophical
divide on what is necessary to get cooperative
action that would lead to growth for the global
economy.
FISHER: Yes, sir.
Here in the red tie.
Here comes the mic.
Q: Ed Cox, New York State Republican Party
and director of Noble Energy.
In the upstream oil-or taking the sand hill
argument one step further-in the upstream
oil and gas sector, I have seen the availability
of equity, bond markets hedging very important
recently, doing strategic mergers.
The financial sector has really permitted
the upstream oil and gas sector to drive innovation
and produce cheap oil and gas.
That has been really tremendous impact-positive
impact for our economy, and frankly the world
economy.
So where has the financial sector gone wrong
with respect to that important area of our
economy?
STIGLITZ: OK.
Well, let me just say something.
It may-
LIPSKY: (Laughs.)
About fossil fuels?
STIGLITZ: Well, there are two things-two things
where I think there's a problem.
One was the question of did they overinvest
in the same way they overinvested in houses
in the Nevada desert?
And what we now know is that almost surely
they did.
And there's a wave of bankruptcies going on.
So from that-even from that narrow point of
view, there was not management of the allocation
of resources.
It was important-OK, I know you'll disagree.
The second one is, the oil and gas market
does not reflect the real social cost of carbon-of
carbon emissions, which is very, very high.
And therefore, there's been overexpansion
of that sector relative to renewable energy.
So in my mind-but that, I don't blame the
financial sector.
FOROOHAR: I would-
STIGLITZ: But that is public policy.
We should have had a public policy to deal
with the social cost of carbon.
And they're responding to-so I don't blame
the financial sector for that at all.
They're just responding to the failure of
government to-you know, or collective action
to-
FOROOHAR: Also, the commodities sector, one
of the reasons it's so volatile is it's become
one of the most highly financialized sectors.
I mean, you know, a lot of-a lot of money
has gone into commodities-raw commodities
or plays on commodities.
And you see that flowing out.
And I mean, you know, hedge funders themselves
would say that.
There's plenty of Senate testimony on the
topic.
LIPSKY: Yeah, although outside of energy the
size of the commodity markets is much smaller
than people understand it.
STIGLITZ: But let me just raise one question
that Mark Carney has raised, who's the head
of the Bank of England, and I agree.
And that is, embedded in our current financial
market is a contagion risk that we haven't
really, fully taken into account, that if-we
ought to be thinking, what will happen if
the-we finally do put a price of carbon, or
we recognize that, you know, global warming
is really serious?
Then the price of those carbon assets are
going to go down.
You know, there will be these calculations
that a very large fraction of reserves are
going to have to stay in the ground.
And if you look at the network-the financial
network, firms that own assets that own assets
that are related to the financial sector,
it is-there is a systemic problem of a very
significant order of magnitude that has not
been fully incorporated-
LIPSKY: Right, but, Joe, let me say, you can
be sure that senior management of large financial
institutions that have long-lived assets are
thinking hard about this topic, absolutely.
STIGLITZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
FISHER: Question in the back?
Yes, ma'am.
Q: Bhakti Mirchandani, One William Street.
Thank you for a wonderful discussion.
Earlier in the discussion, there was talk
of the perimeter of regulation being too narrow.
What would you ideally like to see in terms
of the systemically important institutions
that are outside that perimeter?
How would you like to see them regulated?
LIPSKY: Well, without getting specific about
how do you regulate the insurance business,
how do you-et cetera.
But essentially, what we saw was the ability
to collect-to create pools of leverage outside
of the regulatory system.
AIGFP, Countrywide Finance, et cetera.
And it seems to me that there needs to-we
need two things.
We need to find a way to make sure that these
sources of leverage are fairly regulated,
or else you've got exactly what Rana was talking
about, is the risk will move to the less regulated
spot and it can become excessive and distorted.
Secondly, an aspect I remarked, but I think
has been underappreciated, is how much the
post-crisis regulation has tended to be based
on national boundaries, and how the initial
effort to create a level playing field by
regulatory reform, I would say, has not succeeded.
And as a result, has become a barrier to,
I think, the more efficient development of
cross-border flows.
And hence, it is not the only reason, but
it is not so surprising that for the first
time since World War II, since the crisis
global trade has grown more slowly than global
GDP.
And I think that's a sign that shouldn't be
just excused away.
And I think there's some cause and effect
here.
STIGLITZ: Yeah.
Although, let me just say, from a longer-term
perspective, as we move more to a service
sector economy, I would have expected that
to happen.
So again, many factors and it's correlation
versus causation.
FOROOHAR: And digital trade flows are actually
exponentially growing.
It's real, you know, physical goods.
So, can I just add one thing to this?
Which is, you know, I'm not an expert in regulation,
and I won't pretend to be.
But I think an interesting question would
be also how to incentivize the behaviors that
we want, versus just regulating the behaviors
that we don't want.
It has always seemed to me that, you know,
the basic question is, is an institution,
is a company providing a clear, measurable
good?
And if they are, let's reward them for that.
Let's incentivize that.
And that might go to some broader conversations
about the tax code and how it subsidizes debt
and leverage, versus equity and savings.
FISHER: Yes, ma'am.
Last question.
LIPSKY: Aww.
Q: Pat Cloherty, venture capitalist.
What would you think of the idea that excessive
regulation, in many ways, provides the basis
for growth?
And having been in this business 45 years,
I've watched AT&T be dismantled, all kinds
of regulation there, and the downstream consequences
for innovation in telecommunications were
vast, for an unregulated-then-unregulated
sector.
Likewise, IBM-the breakup of IBM.
So we get the downsizing of computers, so
there were antitrust, all kinds of regulations.
So is it perverse to think that maybe extending
the boundary of bank regulation would not
be a good idea?
FISHER: Can we ask you each to take a bite
at this, and each get a last word in?
And then we'll end.
So, John.
LIPSKY: OK.
Yes, that is definitely a risk.
That I wanted to point out, there's a big
difference, for example, between the Japanese,
European economies on one hand and the U.S.
economy on the other in terms of the relative
role of regulated finance-i.e., banks, commercial
banks, as a source of funding-versus more
market-driven securities markets.
And what you see, and it's, of course, post-crisis,
that the securities markets have driven a
cleaning of the balance sheet.
It doesn't prevent mistakes, but when mistakes
are made they get recognized and dealt with
very quickly, then you move on.
Whereas, there has been a tendency in the
much more highly regulated commercial banking
system, they're very slow to recognize losses,
very slow to create realistic valuations.
And that has clearly inhibited growth to the
point that the U.S. economy is now-what, GDP's,
what, 10 percent above where it was pre-crisis?
And in the European Union, they are just back
to pre-crisis levels now.
And I-
FISHER: Joe, your last word.
STIGLITZ: Well, the last point, I guess I
can't help-(inaudible)-(laughter)-the main
reason for that is the euro-I have a book
coming out, and I shouldn't mention this,
but on the devastating effect of the euro.
And that's the real reason for the problems
in Europe.
The broader point that you made, which is
that there are often, almost always unintended
consequences that you can't fully take into
account, when we look at that particular experiment,
breaking up AT&T, we have to remember that
AT&T was very important in bringing the transistor,
a lot of innovations, basic research.
It wasn't very good at bringing the last mile,
bringing the goods to the market.
But in terms of basic research, it was phenomenal.
It had more Nobel Prizes than any country,
outside the United States.
So the point is that was an unintended consequence.
I think there's been a slowdown of some of
the basic research, as a result of that.
Nobody intended that.
The broader view-my last word-is just to reiterate
what Rana said, that our major challenge is
to try to figure out how to make sure that
our financial system does what it's supposed
to do.
And too much of our discussion has been trying
to prevent the problems of the things that
it's gone wrong.
You know, we have to do that.
You know, we have to stop all the bad things.
But in all that discussion, there's just been
two little questions.
What are the core functions?
What would a banking system-or, not a banking
system-a financial system that really fulfills
that?
There's been a little bit too much faith,
in this discussion between markets and institutions,
markets and banks, a little bit too much faith,
I think, in markets.
I think institutions like banks are really
important.
They're good at information, theoretic reasoning
for that.
So I think we've lost sight of the bigger
picture, and that as we begin-continuing our
discussion of reform-regulatory reform, I
think we ought to put a lot more emphasis
on the bigger picture.
FISHER: You get the last, Rana.
FOROOHAR: I will just take a kind of existential
step back and just say: I think de-siloing
the debate, realizing that making a healthy
capital market system is not just about formal
banking, it's also shadow banking, it's tax
policy, it's housing policy, it's retirement
policy and pensions.
We haven't even gotten into that whole topic.
And that it has to really be about all those
pieces, because they interact together.
And I also think that just changing the narrative-I
feel like there's been a sense that finance
was the kind of tippy-top of the services
economy pyramid that we're all supposed to
aspire to.
You know, after you graduate from being agrarian
to a manufacturing economy to a services economy?
And I would actually switch it.
I mean, it's called financial services for
a reason, because finance is supposed to serve
business.
FISHER: Thank my trio, and thank the members
for coming.
Thank you all.
(Applause.)
(END)